a poker you have to experiment with
different strategies you have to
actually come up with creative ways of
achieving your goals in this case you
know winning the most chips from your
opponent post game analysis you've got
to look at your results you've got to
look at your strategies figure out which
ones are working figure out why those
are working and then implement those
again and feedback again same in science
you've noticed something happening why
is that happening
is this person breathing really heavily
is it because they've got a really
strong hand or is it because they've got
a really weak hand or is it because
they've just drank too much coffee got
to figure out in some of these these
different variables you might observe
what I've seen this star doing is doing
this how confident am I in in why that's
happening same in poker how confident am
i that my opponent has gone all-in and
is bluffing I'm about to risk all of my
chips on this one thing I've got to
assess my governance levels there's a
ton of crossover between science and and
poker